justin is with us in Portland Oregon I
just an how are you
oh good Dave pleasure to talk to you you
too what's up well my wife and I got
some medical debt here a while back
and we have a bunch of different offices
trying to get money from us and it's a
little bit more than we just pay off a
lot of it like hundred hundred dollars
and we were wondering since it's hard to
keep track of can we maybe get something
to kind of condense those together and
pay on them and get them knocked out
even though they're not interest it's
just such a headache to try to keep all
together and like in line we keep
messing up and how many are there
Oh probably fifteen ten fifteen because
it's just like you know you have the ER
the doctor at the know why is it why is
it difficult to make a list of ten or
fifteen bills and pay them that's for
that unfortunate thing is I didn't have
all of them and then you get another one
and you know just busy with work it's
difficult to try to keep track of them
all you know you're not spending enough
time managing your money right you turn
off the television
I mean seriously making a list of ten
bills is not that big a deal and
updating it once a month I mean because
you got a new one in so what and you
said the balance is only 200 bucks or
something right yeah I think total we
owe about six thousand so which one else
on what's your household income I take
home more about forty five hundred a
month so you know about fifty thousand a
year okay and well that's your take-home
yeah so I will I get eighty if you did
gross okay so you got money going out
for your 401 K yes I have a pension
through ups and then I also have like I
think ten percent going for you people
okay yeah I would temporarily stop that
until you clean this mess up and I would
get you on a written detailed budget you
should be able to pay this $6,000 off in
six months and be done with it and those
little bitty ones will all be gone in
one month the
$100 ones and $200 ones they'll be gone
in a month once you start doing a
written budget each month so are you a
UPS driver yes sir I do
Freight for them like semi trucks and
like oh you're gonna be the truck driver
okay you know a delivery driver alright
and what's your wife do okay all right
are you home every night or you do over
the road no I'm a local pickup deliver
we just do phrase just like QPS but
imagine heavy stuff gotcha so it's like
local Freight it's all in town yeah I
gotta say but you're still working your
butt off
I mean you UPS guy you work and are 10
12 hours a day five days a week so yeah
that's why it's hard to get time to deal
with you know yeah five days a week yes
sir that leaves two off days budget
budget an hour budget uh now are you and
your wife set aside no kids no TV and
start doing your written plan because
here's what's gonna happen when you
write it all down
you're gonna smack yourself in the
forehead and go dad gummit I feel like I
got a raise because your fact that
you're not making this behave is causing
all these little mosquito size bills
buzzing around your head to give you
great stress and they're too small to
give you great stress yes sir of course
I had in this same topic here is we have
a twenty thousand dollar car loan but
instead hundred thousands bumper my a
hundred thousand mile bumper-to-bumper
warranty it's three new cars reliable
other cars paid off we were wondering if
we should sell that get out of the
foreigner dollar a month payment and buy
her mom's car that's been gently used
for you know four or five thousand bucks
alone again but much less if you're not
going to sell it you need to look at
your budgeting process that we're
talking about and be able to see your
way to pay it off within two years I
think you could be debt-free all the
medical bills in the and the car loan do
you have any other debt that is not your
home we just rent the home from her
parents on the home which rent out for
them so I think that's not it actually
so here's what's happening okay what are
you guys twenty-eight mid-thirties
mid-thirties okay here's what's
happening you guys work your butts off
and the money comes in
the money goes out and you have no idea
where it went you're just normal people
you were you work really hard and you
work too hard to be broke as you are you
related I mean you work hard both of you
stand on your feet
cutting hair on an easy job putting out
on people not an easy job delivering the
stuff you know the work you're doing
it's not easy job so you guys are
working your tail if you work too hard
to be broke and so I'm going to
challenge you and we'll be your coach
I'm gonna do locker room and say all
right
halftime I'm puking out there in the
second half and a win because you're
behind on your score right now by
$26,000 and either gonna sell this car
or gonna pay it off but I think you can
pay it off if you like it yeah we do
okay and then you're going to just start
making intentional very careful
decisions with every dollar and it
doesn't take an hour a week to manage
this that's all it takes and to make
these dollars behave but you guys are
just run run run run and you're really
tired when you get home you don't feel
like screwing with anything right and so
that's why you got to set aside like
some weekend time or something and just
go okay this is our time and this is the
time we're going to commit to spending
on managing money we're gonna get to
every dollar app it's free to use for
your phone or your or your desktop
either one you and your wife sit down
and give every one of your dollars of
income a name before the month begins
stop your 401k temporarily stop have
anything come by your check get as much
money coming home as possible and then
we're going to attack that twenty six
thousand dollars with a vengeance if
you'll do that you can turn this around
if not you're gonna work your whole life
and you're gonna end up with an old pay
for car and no money other than what you
put into your 401k and what you know
what they set aside for you at work but
that's just if you'll do this on purpose
you'll have millions of dollars more and
you'll have a lot less stress on purpose
so that's what you need to do dude hey
thanks for the call